LARRY ARNN: The Fall
Convocation Talk
is given by the
professor of the year.
This one is particularly
delightful to me.
He will give the first speech
by a baby from this podium.
[LAUGHTER]
Like half the people
in the county,
he is the offspring of
David and Janet Whalen.
So, you can't turn
around without running
into one of them.
And this young man--
how old are you, Ben?
SPEAKER 2: 35.
SPEAKER 1: 35, so I've
known him since he was 15.
See?
That was a subtraction problem.
And, what was he
like when he was 15?
Well, in one way,
he is then exactly
as he will be when he's
80, he's baby faced.
Also, he has that charming
smile and engaging way that
just makes him seem friendly.
He grew up with a
bunch of friends.
Patrick did too, at least
two of the boys did.
And they're like
really rough customers.
They played rugby and they
hurt each other all the time,
and then they can
sing like angels.
And so, of course, there's
larceny in the boy.
He and four of the
boys, three others,
went to Europe twice, and
bused all over Europe,
and came back with
money in their pocket.
And I made him stand up in
my house years and years ago.
We'd been pheasant shooting,
and the boy can shoot too.
We cooked the pheasants
and were eating them,
and I made those boys just
stop by and I made them sing,
and they really could sing.
And then, Ben Whalen
looks so dang pretty,
you can see why people put
a lot of money in his bucket
when he was singing.
He was the Whalen kid
that was most noticeable.
He's going to be a
college professor.
He just has such an open
warmth for knowing things,
and such a ready ability
to identify what is known,
what is best to be known.
He took up English.
I guess you'd say
like his daddy.
I remember he went to
the University of Dallas
and you went to
University of Nevada,
Las Vegas, where
oddly enough, there
was a great English professor.
I remember, it was a happy day
when David came into my office
and said, the English department
is interested in hiring
Ben for a one year appointment.
I said that's the most wonderful
news, and he said wonderful?
And I said, yeah.
I said, you came to tell me that
you can't be involved in that.
And that means that
that boy belongs to me.
And then sure enough
later, they wanted
to make him stick around here.
And then sure enough later, he
won the professor of the year.
He is a golden young man.
Ben Whalen, professor
of the year.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN WHALEN: Thank you, Dr. Arnn.
That's a very kind introduction.
I apologize to you all.
As I stepped on the
platform, my glasses broke.
It seems somehow fitting
in 2020 to give an address
to an audience.
I can't see, with a
text I can't read.
[LAUGHTER]
On June 12th, 1592, when the
budding young actor Shakespeare
was just 28 years old and
fresh on the scene of London,
a riot rocked the
English capital.
Apparently, an apprentice
to a felt maker
had been arrested
and thrown in prison
under dubious circumstances.
His fellow felt
making apprentices
gathered in the Southern
District to protest.
It was an area pocketed
with taverns and theaters,
and was where
Shakespeare performed.
The protest drew a large
crowd and became violent.
Supported, as the
mayor of London
describes things, by
quote, "a great number
of loose and masterless men,
act for such purposes as riot."
The mayor, William Webb,
responded with vigor,
arresting the principal and
violent actors of the riot.
The Elizabethan government
was made uneasy,
however, and when the rumors
spread that the film maker
apprentices were
planning a second tumult,
the Privy Council
deployed an armed watch,
forbade certain forms
of public gathering,
and shut down the
theaters for three months.
It was a hard blow
for those who had made
the theater their profession.
Indeed, the suspension
of the theaters
lasted far longer than the
initially planned three months.
Later in the year, a large
outbreak of the bubonic plague
swept through England.
And as the government tried to
limit the spread of the plague,
it forced the theaters
to remain closed
for much of the next
year and a half.
What was Shakespeare to do?
Here was a young man
just come to London,
just beginning his career,
facing a country convulsed
by riots and a deadly disease.
Shakespeare did
what any of us would
have done in such a situation.
He organized a Zoom
rendition of Hamlet.
[LAUGHTER]
Notably, with his means
of employment gone,
Shakespeare turns to
his poetry, producing
the only narrative poems
that he ever wrote,
Venus and Adonis and
The Rape of Lucrece.
Both of these are some of the
very finest narrative poems
in our literary tradition.
Venus and Adonis, a
playful meditation
on love and desire,
while The Rape of Lucrece
is a serious examination
of the nature of suffering,
the abuse of power,
the foundations
of human government, and ancient
Rome's transition from monarchy
to a Republic.
We probably would
be willing enough
to excuse Shakespeare
had the plague,
with its many deadly terrors
and surely daily nuisances
and worries, occupied
all of his attention
and prevented him from writing,
or at least drive him well.
We probably would
be willing enough
to excuse Shakespeare had
his imagination been occupied
by visions of hordes of felt
making apprentices pouring down
the streets, felt in
hand, ready to light it,
and watched London burn.
Indeed, it is rather
remarkable that although waves
of the bubonic plague swept
through England several times
during Shakespeare's
youth and adulthood,
for instance, the
year he was born,
it killed one out of every
five people in his hometown
of Stratford, one out of five.
Shakespeare rarely
mentions it in his works.
It is surprising, even
perhaps a little odd,
to find how little notice,
how little attention,
Shakespeare seems to give
to this deadly disease.
It's almost as if
Shakespeare is calling
us to look at other
things, higher things
than the banal facts
of disease and death.
And it's not that Shakespeare
is an escapist in his poetry,
nor is he a blinded idealist.
As I mentioned, he wrote
about suffering extensively.
But Shakespeare is
less interested in all
of the different things that
might cause mankind misery
or death, and is more interested
in how we might suffer or die
well.
How we might find meaning
or redemption, or grace,
in the concrete fact that
we all will suffer, and are
bound to become dust.
Faced with that grim
reality, Shakespeare
turns to the higher
things, to search out
the springs of mercy and
justice, of love and nobility,
of sin and forgiveness.
But if Shakespeare,
confronted with civil disorder
and terrible disease, was still
able to turn to higher things,
perhaps that was
simply because he
was Shakespeare, a genius
unequaled in our tradition.
Perhaps in his
greatness, we can't
find an example for ourselves.
Let me tell a second story that
I take from James Shapiro's
book, Shakespeare in America.
In January 1846,
part of the US army
found itself stationed
in Corpus Christi, Texas
to prepare for the outbreak
of the Mexican-American war.
Corpus Christi was described
by one officer as quote,
"the most murderous,
thieving, gambling, cutthroat,
godforsaken, hole in Texas."
And if you know Texas,
that's saying a lot.
The troops were growing idle,
and idleness and godforsaken
holes are not a good match.
To counteract this John B.
Magruder had the soldiers build
a large theater, and
then organized them
for the production of several
plays, Shakespeare's Othello
among them.
In the initial casting,
the part of Desdemona,
Othello's beautiful
wife, was given
to James Longstreet, the man
whom Robert E. Lee would soon
call his old warhorse.
Longstreet was a
big man, standing
at 6 foot 2, more than 200
pounds, and with a long beard.
They decided he didn't look
quite right for Desdemona,
and instead, they gave the
part to the shorter, lighter,
Ulysses S. Grant.
Grant, however, was too brisk,
and the soldier playing Othello
grew frustrated,
complaining quote,
"I cannot pump up any
sentiment with Grant dressed up
as Desdemona."
They eventually sent to have
a professional actress come
and so resolved the difficulty,
though Longstreet did note
in his memoirs that
Grant quote, "looked
very like a girl dressed
up but he did not
have much sentiment."
Now, I admit that I
share this story in part,
because I simply delight in
the thought of Ulysses S.
Grant, future president
of the United States
in a dress playing the
gentle, elegant Desdemona.
But the more I thought
about it, the more
I've understood the
significance of this action.
Magruder, Longstreet, Grant,
all tough men, men of action,
men preparing for
bloody deeds, men
who would play decisive roles
in the terrible conflict that
would determine the course of
our great nation's history.
When caught in a
godforsaken hole trying
to manage soldiers
and prepare for a war,
they too turned to
the higher things,
to the fine and delicate
domestic tragedy of Othello.
This wasn't just busy
work for idle hands.
They could have
made the soldiers
dig ditches easily enough, or
any other form of manual labor.
No, Magruder,
Longstreet, and Grant
were engaged in a
much harder toil,
of civilizing men,
of building culture,
of taking the finest things
that have been handed down to us
and making them live
again, even in Texas.
But if Shakespeare's London
or Grant's Corpus Christi
seemed too far away from
us, we are at Hillsdale
blessed to have a
long and noble history
that we might look to as well.
We all know, of course our
college's great triumph
during the American Civil
War, when our young men went
to fight for our Union and
when our college nevertheless
continued its mission to
furnish all persons who
wish irrespective
of nation, color,
or sex, a literary, scientific,
and theological education.
These are the higher
things, and our college
followed its mission even in
the darkest days of our country.
But given our current
situation, my thoughts
turn to the Hillsdale
College of 1918.
In the spring of that year,
with World War I raging,
the United States government
established the Student Army
Training Corps, a program where
male students at liberal arts
colleges across the country were
enlisted in a program jointly
administered by the
government and the colleges,
in which the young men
received both military training
and a liberal arts education.
The men were formally enlisted
as privates in the US army
and subject to military law.
Additionally, the US government
paid their tuition and fees
and they received a
salary of $30 a month.
Hillsdale College was selected
to host one such program,
and 195 of our young
men enlisted in it.
There was a barracks built right
there, down Manning Street,
in the old shoe factory.
The young men of Hillsdale
lived in this barracks, engaged
in drills, parades,
and training,
while also attending
college classes.
We have wonderful records in
The Collegian of the goings on.
Of course, with the
men busy in training,
The Collegian was mostly
written by the young women
of our college.
And we have many little notes
about how fine the men looked
in their uniforms, and how
lonely the dining hall was
with all of the men gone.
In the evenings,
to Hillsdale women
would gather down the street
to watch the Hillsdale men
parade for the lowering of the
flag and the retreat ceremony,
and then return to
their residences
and do what they have always
done at Hillsdale College,
surpass the young men in their
study of Latin and Greek.
[LAUGHTER]
But in 1918, we didn't
only have a world rending
conflict of mind
boggling proportions,
we also saw the
terrible outbreak
of the infamous
Spanish influenza.
Hillsdale, of course, was not
untouched by the 1918 pandemic.
Students became sick.
And one of our
students, a young man
in the temporary barracks of
the Student Army Training Corps,
died of the virus in
December of that year.
He was Harry Kelly, part
of the class of '22, 1922.
He was 21 years old,
and The Collegian
reports that he quote, "rendered
faithful and efficient service
in the Student Army
Training Corps."
I want to think about
him for a moment.
He walked the same
campus where we now sit.
He saw the same hills.
I have trees in my
backyard that are
much older than he was, and he
might have seen or sat under it
had he strolled past the
Hungry Howie's of yore
onto Norwood Avenue.
Why was he here?
What was he doing?
Why, with the world falling
apart in disease and war,
did the young man come
to Hillsdale College
to enlist in the Student
Army Training Corps
and study both soldiery
and the liberal arts?
Why did he do this, risking his
very life which he duly paid?
Why did the young
women of the college
attend, despite the
conflict and the influenza?
Why study Latin, or
Shakespeare, or physics,
at such a time when
there are so many more
pressing and practical concerns?
Our studies here
point beyond and above
the quotidian mess of
conflict and disease
that is the constant
companion of mankind.
It isn't that we ignore
or dismiss the suffering
that conflict and
disease brings.
These are real aspects
of our existence,
and we must exercise
prudence and fortitude
in confronting them,
as well I think,
as praying for the gifts of
faith, hope, and charity.
But we must never be
governed wholly by them.
To have one's actions,
finally determined
by conflict or disease
is to be subject to them,
to become slave to them.
The free man or
woman, deliberately
educated man or
woman, retains always
the sense of that which
is higher and finer.
Those permanent things,
those transcendent truths,
that rightly order
our existence,
and give our lives meaning
even in the face of suffering,
And so, friends, I can only
end in expressing my thanks
and admiration.
I am deeply grateful
to our administration,
to our students, and to
the faculty and staff.
Despite the tremendous headwinds
we have faced as a college,
we continue to pursue our
mission, and the great and good
of the noble endeavor
we are engaged
in with vigor and courage.
I have never been so proud to
be a part of Hillsdale College
as in this year, in
these trying times.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]